Welcome, everyone. Thank you for joining. Welcome to ACR.
So this educational session is entitled Targeted Alpha and Beta
Emitting Radiopharmaceuticals: Multidisciplinary Precision Radiation
Medicine.
And
so I'm very proud to introduce my speakers, appreciate their
willingness to join for this. And our first speaker today,
Dr. Delphine Chen,
professor in nuclear medicine and radiology at the Fred Hutch
Cancer Center, who'll be talking to us about quantitative molecular imaging to
enable personalized radiopharmaceutical therapy with alpha and beta emitting
isotopes. Welcome.
Yeah, thanks. Thank you so much. Ooh, sorry about that.
Thank you so much for the invitation to speak, and
we'll look forward to diving into this. So here are my disclosures.
So we're going to talk about quantitative imaging and how that could help us lead
to personalized approaches for alpha and beta emitters.
So we will look at
some of the ways that molecular imaging helps us with that, how PET quantification
can help with patient selection, and other aspects of
predicting response and determining prognosis, and looking at
quantitative SPECT.
So in terms of personalizing our treatments, as you know, we are
looking at the distribution of a radiopharmaceutical, and we can use
imaging to help us determine whether the expression of that target is present,
so that when we give our radiopharmaceutical drug, we know that it's
going to target those tumor sites.
And using that imaging, we are essentially, in a way, phenotyping
that patient to determine what is that expression level and whether it's worth
treating with the radioactive drugs.
We can also look at dose delivery including drug
retention. So that's where the dosimetry aspect comes into play, as well
as with the radiation delivery.
So quantitative imaging with PET and SPECT are helpful.
PET is inherently, as you know, a quantitative imaging modality, and SPECT is also
now quantitative as well. So in terms of ways we can
quantify the images,
there are different levels of quantification.
Probably what we're most familiar is with a relative to organ scoring
system that's used for both
dotatate PET and PSMA PET referencing, like liver and spleen,
and how avid is the tumor relative to those organs.
We can also use semi-quantitative measurements.
I think everyone's familiar with the SUV, standard uptake value.
You can look at the maximum or the mean per lesion.
You can also look at the mean for the total tumor volume.
You can actually do a functionally defined or biomarker
defined tumor volume using PSMA uptake or
dotatate uptake to then define what your tumor volume is.
And finally, you can use dynamic or multi-time point imaging, which is the most
common approach and probably best approach for looking at dosimetry, and you can
also use that for pharmacokinetic and pharmacodynamic measurements.
We won't go into that pharmacokinetic and dynamic
measurements so much, but just to be aware that those
are assessments that you can do with
quantitative imaging as well if you're looking at on-target interactions and
off-target interactions.
So let's look at intensity scoring relative to reference organs.
We'll review NETTER-1 and two, and then the VISION trial.
So VISION, and I should say,
therapy also had this reference, but they actually had more
quantitative metrics included. So in both NETTER-1 and
NETTER-2, we looked at somatostatin receptor imaging that was used to define who
was eligible to be treated with lutetium dotatate.
In NETTER-1, the modality was indium-11 penetreotide, so Octreoscan,
and they were scored. They had to have uptake that was either
equal to the liver or above
on all evaluable images. And as you know, this
recruited the low-grade, Grade 1, Grade 2, well-differentiated neuroendocrine
tumors.
In NETTER-2,
the modality is now switched to PET. It was now more widely available.
They allowed also the indium-111
penetreotide scans, as well as tech-based planar scans for
somatostatin receptor expression assessment.
And now they restricted the eligibility to have a
higher level of uptake, so they required that the
uptake in the evaluable lesions had to be at least above the liver.
It couldn't be similar to the liver.
So when you look at the outcome, so everyone's familiar with these survival curves.
Clearly, there was a benefit in receiving lutetium dotatate.
But what's interesting is in the post hoc analysis, when you looked at the
somatostatin receptor expression, even if you had uptake that was similar
to liver or between liver and spleen,
the
benefit that you would receive from lutetium dotatate was very similar to those who
had higher level uptake, which was above the spleen or markedly avid.
Similarly, in NETTER-2, then when they did their post hoc analysis
looking at the scores between score three and four, there wasn't a large
difference in terms of the outcomes with treatment with lutetium dotatate relative
to the intensity. So these trials suggest that in,
at least for lutetium-177 dotatate or
somatostatin receptor, if you want to extrapolate beyond lutetium-177
dotatate, but at least for that drug,
the intensity doesn't seem to have a huge impact, at least when you look at
it from this angle relative to the reference organ.
Just to be aware, one of the challenges with using reference organs, though, is
that the biodistribution can be changed.
The normal biodistribution of the tracer on imaging can
change relative to other drugs or other biological processes or physiologic
processes. So one of them that has been better characterized is the
impact of having somatostatin analogs on what a
somatostatin receptor PET image would look like.
So because the somatostatin analogs bind to the same sites as where dotatate,
dotatocicium, or any of the other PET agents
bindThere was always the concern that you would have competitive
inhibition and inability to see the uptake in the tumors if you had
the somatostatin analogs on board.
But what we found, and there are at least three papers that I know of, and maybe
a few others. But the three earliest papers showed that what happened when
you gave the somatostatin analogs is that it decreased the amount of
activity in the background in the liver and the spleen, and then you could
see the uptake in the tumors better.
And when they did quantitative measurements, the SUVs would actually even go up
with the somatostatin analogs. And that was tested even giving the
somatostatin analog shortly, within 11 days of doing
the dotatate or somatostatin receptor PET, and up
to a month prior to doing the dotatate PET.
So that is just one thing to keep in mind in terms of when you're
using the reference organs
for that, and we'll see a similar thing with PSMA.
So in the post hoc analysis, just to look at other quantitative
ways of looking at the PET information.
When you look at the liver tumor burden, there was a post hoc
analysis looking at what metrics in the liver would potentially predict
response, because the presence of liver metastases,
that tends to be the cause of mortality in neuroendocrine
tumor. And what you can see is that the amount of liver tumor
burden based on the segmentation with a somatostatin
receptor agent didn't seem to have any impact on the
clinical benefit from lutetium dotatate treatment.
But if you had the presence of at least one large liver lesion
greater than three centimeters, that had a significant impact on how
well those patients responded. So these are other ways that we can
look at quantitative imaging to help
predict which patients are going to respond better versus not.
Switching now to lutetium PSMA. So our two
largest, or the two earliest trials looking at the benefit of
lutetium PSMA for metastatic castration-resistant prostate cancer
are the, excuse me, the VISION trial and the THERAPY trial.
So the VISION trial was lutetium PSMA plus standard of care
versus standard of care in the control arm, and THERAPY was lutetium
PSMA versus cabazitaxel in those patients
who their next best management step was going to be treatment with
cabazitaxel.
In terms of the imaging that was required to allow them to
proceed with treatment with the lutetium PSMA.
For VISION criteria , PSMA uptake had to be above the background
liver intensity, and they couldn't have any PSMA negative disease, was
defined by any node that was greater than two and a half centimeters, or
solid or bone
soft tissue lesions that were greater than a centimeter.
And that is, of course, to overcome the potential partial volume averaging effects
you might have with smaller lesions on PET imaging.
FDG PET was not used for eligibility.
It was purely based on the PSMA PET findings.
In THERAPY,
like I said, they had actually these quantitative criteria.
So not so much just relying on the reference organs, but
you had to have at least one measurable lesion with a maximum SUV
of over 20 on the PSMA PET, and all the other measurable
lesions had to have a maximum SUV over 10.
They also did FDG PET and required that there was no discordant
FDG positive, PSMA negative disease sites.
So when looking at the outcomes, we are again, very familiar with
these survival curves in terms of the benefit of lutetium PSMA.
And drilling down into whether the
features on the PSMA PET would predict better response or not.
This is a post hoc analysis of the VISION trial data showing that
what they did was they split the degree of uptake on PSMA
PET by quartiles. And so when you look at the highest quartile, both
for radiographic progression-free survival and overall survival, the
highest quartile had the best outcomes.
And interestingly, there was less of a differentiator between the lower
three quartiles, as you can see from these curves.
What's also interesting is that this is the mean SUV of the PSMA defined
total tumor volume, and you can see that the mean is actually around
10, which kind of aligns
pretty well with the cutoffs that they used in the THERAPY trial,
even though the THERAPY trial was designed earlier.
So
when you look at outcomes from THERAPY, they did a post hoc analysis of the
imaging biomarkers and the ability of those for both
PSMA and FDG to predict response. This is based on the
PSMA PET, so the top row are the patients with lower
SUV means on PSMA, and then above. So
like I said, the SUV mean was not a cutoff, but this is the cutoff they used in the
post hoc analysis, and you can see that it reasonably
differentiates those who had larger responses in
patients who were treated with lutetium PSMA.
The other interesting thing about this, though, is that you can see that there's
still a good subset of patients in the
cabazitaxel treatment group who also had a respond
to their treatment regardless of the PSMA expression.
But probably the bigger determinant of whether
lutetium PSMA would give you a better outcome or not was based on the
FDG data. So now when they looked at the metabolic
tumor volume defined by FDG and looked at smaller versus larger
tumor volumes, you can see that with a smaller FDG tumor volume,
a significantly larger number of those patients actually had a positive response
to lutetium PSMA.
But this actually held over even across with cabazitaxel.
So in general, patients with lower FDG metabolic tumor volumes will generally do
better to treatment compared to those with higher....
treatments. Our group, Dr. Irvani is our diagnostics director and
has led a lot of this work in looking at our data for how you use
imaging biomarkers to predict response.
So this is a recent publication looking at now stratifying patients.
So our clinical practice uses the VISION criteria for
determining whether patients are eligible for being treated with lutetium PSMA,
with some modifications for where they are clinically.
So if they don't have any other good options, they're in reasonable health,
even if the PSMA uptake is lower, we may proceed with treatment as long as there
is actually PSMA uptake. So there may be some minor modifications.
And you will see that in clinical practice, in the published data, that
clinically, sometimes we use other factors besides the imaging to decide whether
we're going to proceed with lutetium PSMA.
But generally, we still want them to have enough
uptake to justify proceeding with treatment.
So,
as I said, in our practice, all of them in this cohort were
eligible by the VISION criteria, and then they further stratified about whether
they would have been eligible for
being treated with lutetium PSMA in the therapy trial using the
therapy eligibility criteria. So here are the cases
looking at--
This is a classic. This would be easily eligible by
either clinical trial or just in general for clinical assessment highly
PSMA-avid disease, no FDG uptake.
But then with therapy, if you had high PSMA uptake but
concordant FDG, you could still proceed as long as the uptake was high enough on
the PSMA. And then the therapy in eligible patients, so low
PSMA with greater
FDG, or just-- Sorry, low PSMA and even
regardless of what the FDG shows, and then discordant disease.
So in looking at the outcomes based on those stratifications, you can see that in
general, those who met the therapy eligibility
criteria actually did better across the board, both for survival and
PSA-defined progression-free survival.
And then when you further stratify this into those who were
therapy ineligible because of low PSMA expression versus
those that had discordant FDG positive, PSMA negative
disease,
you can see that those with discordant disease actually did worse
than those that simply had low PSMA.
And then when you further look at this in survival, looking specifically within
the discordant disease, you can see that those
with
discordant
disease had poor outcomes overall, when you look at the
entire data set.
There's another study that looked at the rates of PSMA and FDG discordant
disease. I won't go into that in detail just for time, but they also did-- This
was in German centers, and they found actually very few patients with
discordant disease. So their conclusion was that FDG could be
helpful still, but they didn't have
strong data to suggest that
FDG was helpful, and that PSMA stratification could
be enough. But
I think this is still evolving data in terms of how FDG PET will be used.
But
I think the data is there to suggest that if you do have higher
volumes of highly FDG-avid disease, probably you're going to do more poorly.
Okay. Moving on to dosimetry. So dosimetry, of course, is what we've
talked about a lot. It's conceptually highly appealing, and on a
physics and biological basis, it makes a lot of sense.
If you can deliver and you can measure that you're going to deliver very high
radiation doses to your tumor sites, that should be able to help you to
tailor the dose. Especially if you know that you're going to avoid, because
of the degree of uptake in your tumor sites, that you're going to
minimize the uptake in your non-off-target sites and minimize the rate
of toxicities, that is really appealing.
And we want to be able to do that to be able to give the maximum
clinical benefit whenever we treat these patients.
It's been challenged by lack of standardized approaches, lots of
variability in terms of both on the image acquisition side, how you
calculate those radiation doses.
And also, there's no data showing that when you do the dosimetry, it
actually has an impact on outcomes.
That said, we're in the early stages, I think, of getting this data.
And so that's where I think the field is in terms of there are lots of efforts
trying to put these kinds of trials together.
So I'm just going to go over a few papers.
This is not going to be an exhaustive review of every single paper out there, but I
think I want to highlight some of the things that we have done and some of the
directions we want to go. So first, dosimetry, as I mentioned,
the classic way to calculate dosimetry is multiple time point
imaging, so you can get a good assessment of the retention of your drug
in the tumor sites over time. So for a clinical practice,
that can be challenging to do every single person, because then they're coming back
for multiple time points over the course of a week to decide what that
dose is going to be and to estimate both the tumor
radiation doses as well as your normal organ
doses. So this study actually looked at single time point
estimations to see if that could be helpful in terms of
identifying those patients that are getting adequate tumor uptake
versus not, and whether it's feasible in terms of calculating dosimetry.
So they took single time point that was generally at about 24 hours after
each cycle, and they used population-based curves to generate their
dosimetry estimates. And what you can see is that interestingly, they saw that
with each cycle over time, the amount of radiation that was delivered, the
lesion absorbed doses decreased with each cycle.
And these are just some cases of some that responded really well to the
lutetium dotatate versus-- Sorry, I think it was a slightly
different peptide, but the lutetium-based dotatate versus--
Sorry, take that back. It was lutetium dotatate.
So
you can see that some were great responders, where they, in terms of the amount of
uptake, so theThus leading to decreased
absorbed doses in the lesions over time.
But others had very stable disease, and stable levels
of delivery of radiation dose.
The overall survival, of course, is 68%.
What's interesting about this study is that they actually had a decent
subset. Over 60% of patients, I think, were also receiving a
radiation sensitizer, so like hypoxanthine or 5-FU.
So that might not apply to general practice, but it was interesting to see
how they were able to calculate these
measurements. The
interesting thing too about this is that they did look at SUV and whether that
could be an appropriate proxy for estimating the dosimetry.
And it turned out the SUV, in the multivariate analysis, did not help
in separating who responded or who didn't.
There are two other papers I'll review really quickly looking at the
maximum tolerated dose for renal dosing.
So this
one was designed to allow patients to get as many cycles up until
their kidneys reached 23 gray. And they did full
SPECT to calculate their dosimetry.
And I'll just call your attention to the top, showing that those who were able to
achieve that maximum tolerated dose actually had
better improved progression-free survival and overall survival
compared to those who did not. This other
study they called the LUMINET trial, which recruited 96
patients. Also, this one used planar imaging for the dosimetry
estimates,
and you can see that there is a nice
subset of patients who actually have a good response
to getting their number of cycles, and you can see the range of
cycles is three to eight. So
one of the other reasons I wanted to pull these two out is that because we use a
standard protocol of four cycles, and at least during these follow-up periods,
which was in the range of 30 to 40 months of follow-up for each of these
trials,
you can see that patients can get more than the four cycles
and not necessarily have toxicity.
Of course, we still need probably longer-term follow-up, but in
one of the papers, they had a small number who developed MDS.
But in terms of looking at the renal site, there was not minimal renal
toxicity.
Then moving on to lutetium PSMA dosimetry.
There are a lot of papers looking at this.
This is a review article showing that you can see that this is sort
of a global look at looking at PSA response.
And of course, those who don't have a PSA response tend to have lower
delivered dose compared to those who have a response.
And in a meta-analysis, they showed that across 29 studies looking at
lutetium PSMA 617 versus INT, another
lutetium PSMA drug, and
hopefully close to clinical
implementation, but we're still waiting for approval.
You can see that there are similar dosimetry estimates between those two
studies. So the SNMMI wanted to
get a handle of what is the variability that we
can expect to see in dosimetry estimates if each center is going to be
performing personalized dosimetry on their own patients with their platforms,
their scanners. And the motivation behind this was that
since we don't have the data to say what that variability is, we can't put
confidence intervals on what our
individual dosimetry estimates are at each site.
So they really set this up to look at tasks,
everything from starting with the image acquisition, like acquisition
protocols, to the final estimate of dosimetry, including software,
how you segment, how you collect the data, and how you represent it, how you
use the phantom data to ground your patient data.
Obviously, this article summarizes the entire dosimetry
challenge, and these were the initial results showing that we did get fairly
similar estimates across when allowing
teams to just do the tasks the way they were going to do it with
certain parameters. They
required segmentation. They looked at segmentation variability.
They looked at the estimate, like which software platform they used to
calculate dosimetry, whether it was voxel-based versus region-based.
And so what they found was that overall, there were actually fairly similar
estimates, which is really encouraging.
So
we're really excited to see this move forward because
knowing how variable it will be will really help
give us confidence in terms of the consistency of
clinical implementation across centers, and certainly will also help
with
how we implement this in clinical trials.
Finally, I'll talk briefly about alpha emitter therapies.
So a lot of the conversation around alpha emitters,
obviously, we're really excited about that because you can get even more
targeted delivery of radiation to the tumor cells with hopefully
fewer side effects if those alpha emitters stay where they're supposed to
go and are not hitting off-target tissues.
One of the questions about actinium-225 is that it has four daughter
alpha emitters that come off as it decays.
So francium-221 and bismuth-213 are emissions that
actually can be imaged on SPECT. And so as part of the ACTION-1 trial, they
imaged these emissions and actually showed that those emissions stay
predominantly where the tumor is.
So they don't actually distribute in a way that leads to a
higher level of
distribution to normal organs compared to tumor sites.
And these are early data, so they showed that here are the hematologic and
renal parameters. There are some minor toxicities, but nothing that is clinically
significant. And you can see at least
based on investigator determination of response, there is
a subset of patients who are responding, and these are patients who've already
progressed on lutetium dotatate.
So this shows that there is the potential benefit of actinium
dotatate to treat patients who have progressed on a beta
emitter therapy.Okay, finally, PET for
upfront dosimetry, I think is also a big
topic that is slowly being evaluated in various early-phase
clinical trials. And
generally, a lot of the dosimetry has been based on the lutetium drug, and
when that's the case, you really can't do upfront dosimetry for that first
cycle if you're going to focus on just using the lutetium drug because you'd have
to give it and then measure the dosimetry afterwards.
There are thoughts out there potentially to use microdoses of lutetium,
and so there's no publicly available data for that yet,
but I think those are just being considered in clinical trials.
But PET can certainly lend itself to helping us estimate the
dosimetry. So as copper-64 and zirconium-89 have longer
half-lives than gallium-68 is just too short of a half-life for us to be
able to image far out enough to understand what
the drug retention is. So the use of these
isotopes has been
incorporated into clinical trials and has been published, and so there is the
potential
to use PET for doing that upfront dosimetry to really
optimize what you give that first cycle.
And I think that's a really attractive idea because usually that first dose is
really important, and we want to get the most effective dosing
upfront. So data is
still being generated, and so I'm really excited to look and see how this
evolves. So in conclusion, we have a lot of different ways to quantify
molecular imaging data. I've shown some of the semi-quantitative and more
advanced quantitative
ways we can do this. Obviously, the simpler ones are going to be easier
to implement clinically and also have a lower burden on our patients.
If they don't have to come back for multiple scans over a week,
that's really helpful on their personal life and
minimizing some toxicity in terms of
taking up their extra time. At the same time, we're
still in the midst of trying to figure out if those semi-quantitative or
abbreviated measures are going to be accurate enough to give us the
level of data we need to really tailor the dose.
So I think this field is rapidly evolving.
We're really excited to have multiple groups working on this.
And so stay tuned, more to come.
Great. Thank you very much.
Thank you, Professor Chen. But you-
Do you want me to stay up here?
Either way. Come over here.
I'll borrow-- Yeah, since I can't see everyone.
Open this for questions.
I'm not tall enough.
Hi.
Just testing. Okay. Dr. Chen, great presentation.
Question for you about some of the co-administered molecules
that people are using to alter the background organ uptake.
So you talked about octreotide, but we know some people are using lysine arginine
or Lysocare. Maybe some people might use something like Jellofusin
to change the uptake. Are you guys looking at
the impact of those on some of the measurements that you have?
Yeah, that's a great question. I'm not aware of other data, so I'll defer to
my colleagues up here if they're aware of any other data
besides the octreotide and even any of the
chemotherapies that we give, because there are lots of combination trials that are
being proposed for lutetium.
So I don't think we have a lot of data to say how that's going to affect the
biodistribution yet. But it's a really great question, and I think it's something
we need to pay attention to. Thanks. Yeah.
I'll offer just one brief addition about that is,
even though there's different ways to augment or change what the uptake is going to
be, the FDA label does have some very specific recommendations for approved agents.
So since we have a diverse group of PET readers outside of research purposes, we're
trying to follow standard protocols on the FDA label for the imaging.
Dr. Chen, thank you for the excellent presentation.
So my question toward the
difference between the PET scan and the SPECT scan.
For my clinical practice, when the same drug labeled with gallium-68 and
labeled with lutetium-177, and I think there's sometimes
discordant between the PET scan and the SPECT scan.
So
what shall we rely more? Shall we rely on the PET scan more or the
lutetium-labeled SPECT scan more?
Yeah. This is for standard of care, like lutetium PSMA-617,
versus the-- Is that specifically what you're referring to?
Or is it also in the for dotatate or any other?
I found that I don't do dotatate or lutetium or the PSMA, but
I do some with FAP. I do some with FAP, and I see the discordant
between the-
Yeah
... gallium-68, a little bit of PET and the SPECT.
So I think that's a great question, and I think that's why there's still an
active discussion on whether PET will give us an accurate estimate.
From my understanding of how these drugs work, the reason I asked that question of
whether you were seeing in dotatate versus PSMA, we've rarely seen it
with dotatate because it's the exact same peptide that's being labeled with
lutetium-177 and gallium-68. PSMA-617 and
PSMA-11 are slightly different analogs, and they actually have different
biodistributions and kinetics. And so in that case, I
would not use PSMA-11 to
do the dosimetry for 617. It would be better to do it just with
PSMA-617. So I think many of the trials that are in
development, it's better to
have the same analog, but at the same time, you can still have similar
analogs as long as you've demonstrated that the biodistribution is similar.
So there's not a straightforward answer to say it's always PET or
it's always SPECT. It depends on the compound and how it behaves.
Thank you.
We have two questions in the chat, but only one minute, so I'll give them both, and
you can fire off quick. Okay. So the first is: Are there any appropriate imaging
criteria that you might use in thinking about selecting a patient for an
actinium versus a lutetium treatment?
And the second is, broadly speaking here-Where do
we stand with single time point dosimetry, and what's it going to take to
get us to be able to do that?
Yeah, great question. So
far, the clinical trials I'm aware of, when you're selecting for actinium-225, they
use the same criteria as for the lutetium drugs.
And second, with the single time point, so it's not an
established technique. I do think based on all the data we have
so far, at least looking at 24 hours is probably the earliest we could look
at to be able to assess what the tumor drug
retention will be, but that's still up in the air.
If you go later for certain drugs, like imaging at day two or day three
after infusion might be better. But I think we're still waiting
for more robust data for that.
Wonderful.
So we'll move on to our second speaker now.
Very happy to introduce Dr. Neil Tonk, who's a
radiation oncologist at the University of Pennsylvania, and he'll be speaking with
us about clinical advances and opportunities in the treatment of prostate
cancer using alpha and beta emitting radiopharmaceuticals. Dr. Tonk.
Great.
Thank you, Dr. Morris, for the invitation, and I want to highlight, it's
been a pleasure to already speak with Dr. Morris and Dr. Chen already.
We all are doing the same things. We're approaching them from slightly different
training pathways, and collaboration is going to be key for the future.
There are some themes that I'll be repeating.
It's not strictly to be repetitive, but to reinforce some of the
concepts that Dr. Chen and Dr. Morris are speaking about, and these are my
disclosures. So we'll first discuss where PSMA
radiopharmaceutical therapy stands in the current
spectrum of cancer care, identify the key potential advantages of alpha therapy
in prostate cancer, and we'll summarize the critical alpha therapy trials in
prostate cancer.
So this is my perspective on the timeline of FDA approvals in
metastatic prostate cancer. I want to highlight the phrase APMR, or Androgen
Pathway Modulation Resistant prostate cancer.
This is the new terminology for metastatic castrate-resistant prostate cancer from
the Prostate Cancer Working Group number four publication, which
was released a month ago. Dr. Chen was on the manuscript.
So the new terminology is APMR. I apologize, some of my slides do have
mCRPC still in them. But endocrine therapies have grown
substantially, and then in parallel, a number of targeted therapies
as well. Radium-223 was approved in the ALSYMPCA trial in
for bone dominant disease, and then lutetium PSMA-617 in
the seminal VISION trial. And what we've noticed is a steady
marching backwards in terms of earlier and earlier stage treatment.
So in the VISION trial, PSMA radiopharmaceutical therapy improved survival in APMR.
This is incredibly important because this is a highly lethal disease.
The median survival of patients who were able to enroll in this trial
was 11 months. So there was a four-month survival benefit
determined with treatment with PSMA-617, which is
life-changing for many of these patients.
These patients were post-taxane with one or more PSMA-avid lesions,
randomized to best standard of care, supportive care versus PSMA therapy.
There was a very importantly improved quality of life with PSMA, reduced
pain,
reduced fatigue. There were higher side effects in the PSMA arm, largely driven by
hematologic toxicity. Very importantly, 30% of patients did
not respond or were resistant to treatment. Dr.
Chen did highlight why some of those things may happen.
For example, low PSMA uptake, and there's a number of additional things,
discordant FDG imaging, tumor genetics.
For example, patients with TP53 somatic mutations probably
do more poorly when given PSMA-RPT, and a number of different factors.
So about a third did not respond or resistant to treatment, but importantly,
overall survival was improved with treatment, which is critical in this disease
entity. PSMA-4 offered, can we give men
radiopharmaceutical therapy even before chemotherapy?
As a Phase 3 trial, patients were randomized after progression on one androgen
receptor pathway inhibitor to switching to another ARPI
versus PSMA-RPT.
The primary findings in the first publication were that it doubles the time to
progression before needing the next treatment.
However, there's no change in overall survival.
There was substantial crossover, and so patients did receive PSMA
radiopharmaceutical therapy eventually.
This is the
overall survival curve. So again, highlight no change in overall survival because
patients were probably given this treatment anyway, but you can offer
patients that are chemotherapy naive
instead of switching an ARPI radiopharmaceutical therapy.
We have not done that for all patients.
The PSMA-ADDITION trial allowed, can we offer men radiopharmaceutical therapy
while they're still hormone sensitive?
So this entity would be called APMS in the new PCWG4
terminology. Phase 3 study, 1,100 men
on an ADT and ARPI backbone with or without PSMA therapy.
Again, improved radiologic progression-free survival.
No overall survival difference. Also importantly, and I think quite meaningfully,
reduced skeletal events. And again, patients were allowed to cross over, probably
mudding the overall survival waters.
So this is the landscape of trials in prostate cancer radiopharmaceutical
therapy.
So published would include VISION, ALSYMPCA,
a number of Phase 2s, some of these Phase 1s, these are reported,
including LUPARP recently, a number of Phase 3
trials in first-line disease,
and then a number of Phase 1 and 2s going to earlier and earlier lines.
And there's several trials that are open, including the STARLET and then the
PROCURE one that are testing men with non-metastatic
hormone-sensitive prostate cancer, so giving RPT at
diagnosis. But it's very important to highlight, at this time,
PSMA RPT is not curative. There's nothing else on this slide.
I just want to highlight that point, is that this is not a curative therapy.
We'd like it to become a curative therapy, but we'd have to optimize patient
selection, and probably combinatorial therapy.So Dr.
Morris is going to go into this more into his discussion, but there's a number of
potential ways that we can exploit and augment radiopharmaceutical therapy to
improve prostate cancer outcomes.
So on the left image over here is perhaps using alpha emitters, which offer more
direct DNA damage,
perhaps leveraging the bystander effect, and also potentially
having immunogenic effects in prostate cancer specifically, which has
historically been thought of as an immunogenically cold disease entity, but
I feel like it's swinging back the other way.
Perhaps including DNA damage response drugs, other ARPIs, immune checkpoint
inhibition, and very excitingly, T-cell engagers, which has become, I'd
argue, one of the most exciting new classes of therapy.
So we'll switch to alpha-emitting therapies next.
This is stepping back quite a bit in terms of really highlighting
radiopharmaceutical therapy and theranostics as a modular platform,
really mixing different radioactive compounds, different linking agents with
different linking moieties
to hit different target proteins on different cancer cells.
So agents can be chelated, which is gallium-68,
lutetium-177, actinium-225, covalently bonded, for
example, astatine-211, or even pre-targeted, so using pre-targeting
methods where
the initial pre-targeted drug binds to the cancer cell and then the therapeutic
is delivered later. So there's lots of different ways that this can
be tackled. There's fundamental differences between alpha and beta
emitting therapies, the common denominator being DNA damage.
But alpha emitting radiotherapies
generally have short energy distributions, high recoil energy, cause
double-stranded DNA breaks. These are the most important molecules.
And beta emitters have a wide distribution of energies, low recoil
energy, often cause single
DNA strand breaks that can lead to double DNA strand breaks, multiple different
types of particles, and importantly, a long range.
So perhaps they may be more relevant for macro metastasis.
In normal tissue versus tumor tissue, alpha and beta particles will
probably have some kind of differential effect, mostly due to tissue
penetration. So in
pink is a tumor type using alpha therapies.
Most of these alpha particles will maybe just go a handful of cell lengths,
perhaps not penetrating as much into healthy tissue, but beta particle
emissions won't be the same. So this invites this concept that
maybe beta emitters may be quite effective for macro metastatic
lesions due to significant tissue penetration, but
also they may offer more off-target toxicity if the bulk of tumor
is by normal tissue. This is a really neat example
of the in vivo alpha path length. This is ovary micrometastasis.
The black bar represents 100 micrometers.
And the alpha emission pathways are
given by example in red, so very, very short pathway lengths.
And this invites this idea that beta emitters may not have the
requisite tumor bulk for this kind of micrometastatic disease.
So this is my take on some characteristics and both advantages and
challenges with alpha therapies.
Higher LET, so perhaps improved killing, limited range in tumor and
normal tissue, much, much more practical shielding and release
requirements. The amount of shielding that is required for alpha therapies is
substantially smaller or substantially less compared to beta
therapies. Lower administered activities as well.
The challenges, however, are still many. Limited range in normal tissue.
It could be a benefit, could be a detriment.
Production and transportation, I'll dive into a little bit more, are an
issue. Unpredictable daughter isotopes that Dr.
Chen alluded to, which we'll dive into a little bit more, and that leads to
potentially higher or less predictable off-target toxicity.
And then Dr. Chen also introduced this concept, but a lack of suitable gamma or
beta emissions for SPECT. So dosimetry is not as robust for
alpha emissions as they are for beta emissions.
But again, this is growing and we expect this to change.
What daughter isotopes are, are the alpha emitter
binds, a daughter radionuclide is emitted while the alpha particle
dislodges. In actinium isotopes, there's four
daughter molecules that can all have a therapeutic benefit that
can launch off of the actinium-225.
So these daughter radionuclides perhaps they need to be accounted for, but they
offer potentially some unpredictable off-target toxicity.
And then depending on the isotope, there's very complex decay pathways
for the multiple different types of alpha radionuclides.
So actinium-225 versus lead-212 versus terbium versus
thorium. The clean ones, quote unquote clean
ones, may include something like astatine-211, which does not have
a daughter isotope. That's not
quantified. This is
a general understanding of alpha radionuclide trial
status.
The only approved alpha radionuclide is radium-223,
which is approved in 2013 for bone-dominant
prostate cancer in the ALSYMPCA trial, which improved overall survival.
And its use has been substantially refined now that
PSMA targeting therapies have arrived.
Actinium-225 is the leader in terms of
trial development. It's a radium metal.
The distribution is over... Sorry, the half-life is over days,
so despite limited production, transportation can be offered to produce these
things. Astatine-211, which we're deeply
involved in, is also in production and early studies.
The challenges are, of course, the half-life is hours.
So again, advantages and disadvantages of multiple different types of
radionuclides.
So this image represents
production challenges and limitations
of the global supply of alpha therapeutics.
And in North America, we are lucky that we are able to
produce all alpha emitters.
Sorry, North America and Europe, we're able to produce all alpha emitters.
However, that distribution of where they're made is quite
variable.There's whole continents that don't have the
production capabilities of
some of these isotopes. So there's quite significant disparities in the
production of these isotopes, which if they were to come into
widespread use in production and distribution,
networks will need to be created to allow patients to have access to all
of this.
This
shows the production locations of actinium-225 across
the world, and this is in the "Alpha
Atlas," which is a really neat publication,
showing where alpha emitters,
actinium-225, is produced. And production facilities are
increasing in pace of development, but coordination
is very, very, very important to ensure that different clinics have access
to these things. So the US Department of Energy is facilitating distribution of
actinium-225. The European PRISMAT consortium
is facilitating the distribution of
actinium-225.
So again, quite a heterogeneous range of
where these are being
produced and how they are being distributed.
So we'll shift the last few minutes
for prostate cancer and alpha emitting therapies, discussing a handful
of trials in development and
where this is going to be going.
So I had highlighted before PSMA radiopharmaceutical
therapy at this time is not curative.
Why alpha therapy is in prostate cancer.
So the high LET killing may overcome the potential relative
radioresistance of aggressive or high-grade disease, potentially
superior for micrometastatic disease given the short path lengths,
potentially reduced off-target toxicity
as a possibility, and then maybe also superior
immune augmentation, which is an emerging area of study.
This is a publication from Mike Sathye, and
taking a number of patients of about 500
men who received 1,200 cycles of
actinium-225 PSMA RLTs, different types.
They received a median of two cycles.
The bulk of these patients were treated on compassionate use
protocols. So
phase three trials are now underway to kind of bolster the
quality of data, but mostly compassionate use.
The median baseline PSA, 170, and about a
third had prior lutetium PSMA RLT.
4% had prior radium treatment.
And in patients, again, with limited treatment options, the median overall survival
was 16 months.
But also very notable is that 70% of patients experienced
xerostomia after one cycle. And in patients that received more than
one cycle, the likelihood of xerostomia approached
100%. So PSMA radioligand therapy
not only binds to prostate cancer, but also targets salivary tissue.
And despite us potentially saying that alpha therapies could
reduce off-target toxicity,
binding in the salivary glands continues to be a very challenging and potentially
dose-limiting option.
But these patients, heavily pretreated, most quite sick,
had robust responses, and there's a number of patients that had
100% decrease in their baseline PSA, which for
patients that are quite sick is absolutely remarkable.
So this
study engenders a tremendous amount of interest of where we're
going to go next.
So this is my perspective on select trials of alpha therapies
in prostate cancer. It's arranged by name on the
left. The phase is by phase one at the top, phase one to
two in the middle, two, and then phase two to three, and three.
The agent,
the patient group, which is nearly entirely APMR,
formerly known as MCRPC, but you'll see some cohorts
also include APMS or androgen pathway modulation sensitive.
Most of these studies are recruiting.
A handful have already been terminated due to developments or
competing trials that have already passed, and the identifier is on the right.
So again, a number of clinical trials that are open.
At Penn Medicine, we have the PSMA Action study that's opening,
and some early results are showing potentially promising
outcomes for these patients of otherwise limited options.
You'll see that most of these patients or most of these ligands are
in late phase are PSMA 617. PSMA INT
is also increasing in use. Antibody therapies, so
J591 or rociparatumab,
the CONVERGE-01 trial is opening.
And then newer
ligands are offering potentially different pharmacokinetics.
For example, PSMA 62 has different pharmacokinetics
and perhaps different
off-target binding compared to PSMA 617.
So even though
we're targeting PSMA, all of these ligands really are not
built the same.
This is an example of a theranostic pair we're developing at Penn
Medicine that's not necessarily specific for prostate cancer, but
can be used, and it will be used eventually in prostate cancer.
The diagnostic tracer is 18F-FTT or
fluorothanetrace. This is built off of a rucaparib
backbone with a covalently bonded 18F.
Rucaparib is a PARP inhibitor, which targets
PARP1. So again, in the theranostic principle, measuring the target
expression with
FTT, giving the theranostic, which I'll talk about, and then you can use it
again to assess the drug dosing.And then this is the
corresponding therapeutic pair,
the astatine-211 parthanatrace, same rukaparib
backbone, but instead of the fluorine moiety, you have a covalently bonded
astatine. So again, this offers a different
way of
treating these diseases.
Interestingly, the astatine-211-PTT
induces this lethal feedback loop in these PARP-1 expressing
tumors. So the subcellular targeting of PTT, since it targets
PARP-1, which is primarily in the nucleus, induces DNA double-strand
breaks,
which
will reduce survival but will upregulate PARP-1 again,
allowing potentially higher drug
binding before cell death. So
we're hoping that we can put these tumors into this death
spiral by drugging this target. This is data
from Mike Farwell,
at Penn Medicine,
showing that PARP1-targeted alpha therapies can enhance target
expression.
This is a neuroblastoma xenograft flank tumor over
here. You get a baseline FTT scan. We see
tumor uptake, gut uptake, which is normal, and then bladder
excretion. And then after PTT
administration, reimage the mice, you don't have immediate killing, but you see
PARP1 upregulation, suggesting that these tumors might take
up more drug, and then by day six, this tumor is already dying or
taking up less
FTT.
So in these mouse models,
this is a control treated with cold drug, and then using fractionated
treatment, you see massive vacuolization of tumors, and in the
fractionated group, substantially improved survival compared to the
controls or
mice receiving a single high dose, which is
lethal. So fractionated treatment might be superior
for
astatine delivery.
So to summarize the clinical investigations in RPT for prostate
cancer,
in APMR, RPT is firmly established, and it is only
growing. The compounded annual growth rate of radiopharmaceuticals
is about 14% per year predicted by most market research,
going into the 2030s. And then two drugs, just
Lutathera and Pluvicto, are already outpacing
spending in all of CMS expenditures of all of radiation
oncology. So it's here, it's growing, and it's going to
continue to get bigger.
Currently, mostly monotherapies of radiopharmaceutical therapy and prostate
cancer are not curative. Alpha therapy offers differential
killing for prostate cancer, and very importantly, and Dr.
Morris' insights are going to be just really enlightening here, combination
therapy as well as optimal sequencing is most likely to be
necessary for optimal outcomes for these patients.
I'd like to thank everyone for their time,
and attending this,
and for your attention right now. Thank you.
Wonderful. Thanks, Dr. Tonk. Open for questions here.
Great
talk.
So do you think the complexity of the outcome deriving from
alpha therapies might be somehow
underestimated also in clinical trials or in patients?
For example, with radium, we have seen a lot of effects
on
tumor cells, of course, but also on bone cells, on bone marrow, and the timing is
very key.
Okay. So, if I interpret the question correctly, the complex
off-target toxicities of these alpha emitters?
Not necessarily off-target, also
targeted effects.
Mm-hmm.
But that implies, for example,
I don't know,
aspects of activating the immune system.
Mm-hmm.
And we think the-
Yeah
... timing is key because with the decay you might have an evolving
landscape of response.
Yeah. That's certainly correct. So
there's emerging data in some publications on clonal
evolution of these tumors with RPT pressures,
and
suggesting that both target expression will change
during the course of treatment as well as different modulations
in both the tumor and tumor microenvironment that, as you get further into
treatment, are offering different mechanisms of resistance.
At its baseline, even before getting to that nuanced part, we know that
there is substantial tumor heterogeneity
within APMR, so some lesions will respond and some
don't. The most basic concept, of course, is that these tumors have different
uptakes.
Both the tumor heterogeneity as well as substantially,
say, poorly understood
clonal pressures
are leading to probably these
differential
tumor responses, and we only have really a handful of phase
three trials in these disease entities.
So further confirmatory trials, I think, will improve our understanding, and
improve translational endpoints are going to be very critical
to essentially homogenize some of these outcomes.
Thank you.
Hi. Really nice presentation. My
question goes for the alpha label rukaparib,
because you say that you can have a feedback positive loop in the tumor,
because PARP is expressed in all the tissues, can be also this happen in normal
tissue, and then you can have off-target toxicity.
Yeah. So the question is this
potential... a feedback loop that can
be lethal in tumor,
and why doesn't this cause the same thing in normal tissue?
The short answer is it can, but
in non-tumor tissue, they're most likely to have
intact PARP1, so the repairability is probably
superior compared to tumor tissue.
So even though we are seeing enhanced toxicity in
addition to acetin, which suffers a proportion will have
dehalogenation or free acetin that can collect in the thyroid, so you do have to
protect the thyroid
during treatment.
Most tissues will repair itself. So we haven't seen the dose limiting toxicities
as much in fractionated treatment because
we are thinking, and it's probably real, that there is a sufficient
amount of normal tissue repair in between each cycle.
Thank you.
Curious, how many of or what proportion of your patients are
actually getting through the full treatment course for
Pluvicto, and what's the most often reason that they're stopping treatment?
Great. Thank you.
So in published data,
for example, the VISION trial, the median number of cycles completed was
five. Patients in the VISION trial were actually
treated with four cycles with an additional optional two.
The community has taken this as a de facto, we should treat them with up to six
cycles. But in the VISION trial, it was a median of five.
In our own institutional database, that is also five.
So we're just about on average. The primary
dose-limiting toxicities are thrombocytopenia
and then anemia.
Rarely xerostomia.
Most patients are terminating treatment early due to disease progression, which is
about that one quarter to one third that are not responding.
Clinicians will get a best understanding of if a disease will
respond to treatment after about two cycles.
So we have this mantra in our clinic, "Every man deserves two cycles
before assessing treatment response."
Thank you.
There's some great questions online.
So, for stromal targets like FAP versus cellular targets like PSMA,
what are your thoughts on whether radioligand therapy can be effective,
alpha or beta, given their range?
Great. So the question was revolving on, I guess, my general thoughts
on if FAP is going to be effective.
I'm hopeful we have FAP trials that are open.
We had a FAP trial
previously that unfortunately closed early, largely due to
poor tumor absorbed doses of less than two to four
gray per lesion. So those really not tumoricidal at all.
So early FAP compounds really suffered
from low tumor retention and then
poor subsequent
administered dose.
Newer compounds, and as a disclosure, we have the Eli Lilly
FIREBOLT trial, that's open and we've already accrued to it.
The ligand has retention going up to seven days, so we think that the
dosimetry will be improved and perhaps the cell killing will be better.
FAP expression in prostate cancer is quite variable, so
we're mostly looking at
FAP targets not in prostate cancer, for example, GI cancers,
melanomas, as well as certain types of breast
cancer.
There's probably going to be differential killing, of course,
between alpha and beta emitters in
FAP molecules. We just don't have enough data yet to say what's
going to happen. And I also want to highlight one last point is
that all FAP is not equal and all
cancer-associated fibroblasts are not equal.
So there's different types of cancer-associated fibroblasts along different types
of tissues.
Yeah, thank you for the excellent talk.
In the previous answer, you said that the treatment response is
assessed after the second cycle.
Mm-hmm.
Can you explain how that is done by PET imaging and the relevance of
that?
Yeah. So, the answer that I'll give is not law,
and it's not necessarily widely a rule, and every clinic has different
understandings of how to assess response.
But our practice is based on the idea that
perhaps the PSA kinetics are rising despite the first cycle due to rapid
increase in tumor before they start treatment.
Then you get blunting of response after the first cycle, and then you may finally
start to see some kind of tumor response, either leveling off or decrease
of the PSA. In our clinic, we've mostly followed patients with
PSA monitoring. Our clinic does not do a lot of
post-treatment SPECT imaging, which some clinics do
post-treatment SPECT imaging on all patients.
The primary way that we assess
response for our patients would be PSA kinetics and then interim
PSMA PET. Different ways that clinics are doing this are every
fraction post-treatment SPECT imaging using a CZT or sodium
iodide, SPECT, whatever you have,
a PET after three cycles or a PET after two cycles, and some
clinics are doing a PET at two cycles and a PET at four cycles as
well. So there's a little bit of variability, and then there's a lot of active
discussion on what is the best way to monitor these patients on treatment.
There's not a harmonized answer.
Thank you.
Okay, we have about three questions online.
I'll do rapid fire in the last minute here.
So,
do you have any thoughts on sequencing alpha versus beta if you were going to give
them to the same patient over time?
Number two, do you get any toxicities,
GI related, in that astatine-211-PTT with that intestinal
distribution? Number three, do you have any thoughts on rhenium-188
relative to other beta or alphas?
Okay.So we'll start with the last question first.
I don't have thoughts on radium-228, so we'll just move on to the next one.
In regards to the GI toxicity,
this has not been done in humans yet.
We hope to complete the IND-enabling work by the
end of this year
or next year, really, to get this going.
But fractionated treatment will probably, and hopefully, mitigate a substantial
amount of the GI toxicity that is expected.
Again, single high-dose fractionated treatment
was lethal
to mice. In regards to sequencing, there isn't
an understanding of optimal sequencing quite yet.
There are some data, for example, the RALLU study that suggests that
sequential treatment could be safe.
So if patients have sufficient hematologic parameters to go on to a next treatment,
they can receive it. They may have a limited response.
And then the Alphabet trial, trying both of those types of agents at
the same time. In the future, it may be that you
give alpha therapies
for biochemical relapse, maybe without measurable disease.
This is pie in the sky stuff. And if they have bulky disease in the future, maybe
you give dosimetrically derived lutetium.
Again, quite pie in the sky stuff. We don't know the optimal sequencing yet.
Thank you, everybody.
Okay. And I have the
privilege to be the additional final speaker here for this session.
My name is Zach Morris. I'm the chair of the Department of Radiation Medicine at
the University of Wisconsin,
and
these are my disclosures.
So, to wrap up this session, I'll focus on, as a physician
scientist, some preclinical and translational work
spanning
lab and phase one investigations, looking at
opportunities where we may combine radiopharmaceuticals with
other cancer treatment modalities.
And I think there's enormous opportunity in this space, broadly speaking.
As a radiation oncologist, I'll lead off with the opportunity to combine with
external beam radiation. Much of what our lab focuses on also has
been combinations with immunotherapy.
I think,
in any of these type of combination approaches, the thought between
combinations with alpha versus beta brings in
rich opportunities for radiobiology, and I think investment in
preclinical and scientific studies is really critical here to optimize
these combinations.
There are a number of other opportunities which I'm not going to go into.
I just will mention
the opportunity to combine with molecular-targeted therapies is enormous,
and we just had a paper accepted on combination with,
for example, DNA damage modulators.
So definitely,
many opportunities beyond what I can cover in one talk today.
One of the agents that I'll talk about here, in particular in our
preclinical as well as early-phase clinical studies, is NM-600.
It's developed by my colleagues, Jamie Weickert, Rainier Hernandez.
I do have a conflict of interest here in that I'm on the advisory board and serve
as a chief medical officer for Arkeis Technologies, which is commercializing this
product.
It's taken up in the membranes of tumor cells in
cholesterol-rich domains, and in that way is not specific
to one certain type of cancer, but can take
advantage of the theranostic capabilities to be selective, potentially, across
many different types of cancer.
And with an agent like that, there's a huge opportunity, I believe,
for combination with external beam radiation.
Using a precursor to this, CLR 131, our
team at the University of Wisconsin, under support from a NIH Head and Neck Spore
grant, led a phase one study in recurrent
head and neck cancer patients where we
determined a prescribed treatment dose of external beam radiation
and then did a single imaging study with this theranostic agent
and performed personalized dosimetry to determine the dose
that could be given from this agent safely while respecting,
in this case, renal toxicity limits, 23 gray to the
kidney, and then simply subtracted that dose from the planned
external beam so that we could potentially give the intended dose of
radiation to the tumor while reducing off-target
in the setting of recurrent head and neck cancer, where off-target dose from
external beam can be quite toxic. And this illustrates the
potential of these types of approaches, where we can deliver on-target
additive effects of radiation dose.
However, we can reduce off-target effects from both modalities,
potentially, or escalate dose to the target tumor, because
our organs at risk for most radiopharmaceuticals do not
overlap much with the organs at risk from external beam radiation.
And as radiation oncologists like Neil and I see
patients each day, it's that last bit of radiation, that
last fraction, that last gray, that often dictates the
degree or presence of toxicities, because when we push the dose,
we're pushing up against toxicity limits.
And it also dictates the likelihood of achieving local control or even
cure. And so the ability to combine these types of treatments,
I think, is a huge opportunity that I hope the field takes a very close look at,
because this is where we may see some of those curative impacts of treatment that
Neil highlighted. And just to illustrate that, this is a patient with a
recurrent adenoid cystic carcinoma in that trial, very
difficult to treat cancer, was able to receive
the radiopharmaceutical in combination with external beam, had quite an effective
response to that.
The areas where I think these types of approaches may be most impactful are
when we think about our normal tissue toxicity profiles
and our tumor response profiles, we typically are talking about
sigmoidal curves. Dose response curves typically are sigmoidal, and the gap
between those two curves, the normal tissue and the tumor, is our therapeutic
window.
That gap is narrow. We have a limited therapeutic window, so the normal tissues
are pushing down our dose limits. And when the dose
that we're delivering is still on the upslope,
the vertical of that sigmoid curve,
that to me is the most immediate opportunity.
So those patients where a normal tissue is limiting
how much we can give from external beam, and where we're at
a relatively low dose, so we're adding more dose to the tumor, would have a
significant effect on tumor control.
One example where I think we could achieve that is in diseases like
medulloblastoma, where these tend to be very radiation
sensitive. However, because they occur in the base of the brain
and they distribute potentially throughout the cerebrospinal fluid, we have a very
large target, craniospinal radiation, and what
we're trying to do here is essentially clear CSF fluid of
tumor cells. However, to do that, the current standard of care requires
use of proton beam radiation, and in exchange for treating the CSF, we're
also unfortunately treating the whole brain and the vertebral
column. This is a treatment that I think could be much better
achieved with molecular targeted radiopharmaceuticals, potentially
intrathecally injected into that CSF fluid, taking
advantage of the molecular targeting of that to potentially reduce the dose of
external beam. We do know that the toxicities of whole brain radiation occur
at relatively low doses, which currently puts a ceiling on how much dose we can
give.
And if we could reduce that, it's very likely we would reduce toxicities.
In fact, that's been seen already when we reduce the dose of external beam.
But what's also been seen is that when we do that, we lose tumor
control. So these are opportunities.
I won't go more into this, but I think this is a huge opportunity for our
field at the interface of radiation therapies to improve
patient care.
I'll transition now to much of what our lab focuses on, which are
the immunoradiological effects of radiopharmaceuticals,
and how we might, through understanding of these, rationally
combine immunotherapies and radiopharmaceuticals.
There are many different effects of radiation in the tumor immune microenvironment.
Some of these are positive, and some of them are negative when we consider them in
light of the potential anti-tumor immune response.
They vary in their dose responsiveness.
Some occur at low doses, some require high doses to achieve, and they
occur over different time courses.
This is a wholesale remodeling on
some level of the tumor immune microenvironment following administration of
radiation. We see inflammatory cytokine release almost immediately.
We see local depletion of radiation sensitive lineages, particularly
lymphocytes. But because of that inflammation, we see a rebound,
often increase in those. That includes a rebound in both
effector as well as suppressor lineages.
We see immunogenic cell death, and that's proportional to radiation dose.
That's tumor cell death that leads to inflammatory
effects. And there's also effects on tumor cells
that are damaged but survive radiation, where they undergo phenotypic
changes such as increased expression of MHC class I,
increased production of type I interferons, which can lead to
changes in their susceptibility to immune response.
So it's a complex biology,
and pre-clinical studies as well as early clinical evidence
suggest that there can be collective systemic effects on
anti-tumor immune response because of these mechanisms.
Those can include effects in priming immune response, which
means generating new adaptive immune recognition of tumor
neoantigens.
There can be effects on simply propagating pre-existing response.
And our group has looked at this in the context of both alpha and beta
emitters.
This is a study that was led by Ravi Patel,
a talented physician scientist now at the University of Pittsburgh.
He was in our lab at the time and looked at combination of NM 600 with anti
CTLA-4, and interestingly showed
that a fairly low to moderate dose
of that NM 600 delivering Y 90 was optimal in
combination with
a checkpoint inhibitor. This was one of our first indicators that
optimal dosing of monotherapy for radiopharmaceuticals
may not be the same as optimal dosing of
radiopharmaceuticals when they're combined with checkpoint inhibition.
In this case, a lower than maximum tolerated dose
was more effective in generating local and systemic response, as well as
immune memory.
In this study with a beta emitting Y 90,
we did not see evidence of immune priming when we did deep sequencing of the T cell
receptor repertoire. We simply saw evidence of clonal expansion of
clones that were present prior to this treatment.
And so this was an example of a combination where we saw an effect in propagating
immune response.
This led to a phase one clinical trial that is now open at the University of
Wisconsin. Dose escalation combining
a low dose Y 90 NM 600 with immune checkpoint inhibition,
and look forward to hopefully reporting back to you on data from
this in the coming year.
Relevant to this session, we did look at different isotopes
in this combination. Caroline Kerr, a
talented MD PhD student in the lab who's now at Johns
Hopkins as a radiation oncology resident, looked at comparisons of Y
90, lutetium, and actinium.
Initial studies in this focused on immune mechanisms and
phenotypic changes on tumor cells.
And what Caroline did to assess this, was to
compare each isotope with external beam, giving the same dose,
either all at once, external beam giving an approximation of the
dose delivered by that isotope each day, so a fractionated
breakdown of external beam to phenocopy the dose rate
of that isotope.Or
a amount of external beam, basically, that gave equal
dose to what the Y90 had delivered by the day
of harvesting of those tumor cells.
This is all in vitro, but she replicated this in vivo.
And what we observed was that, for example, shown here, a type one interferon
response
was activated similarly by each of these isotopes to
external beam. And so the radiobiology was not particularly different from what
we've seen with external beam, but it was dependent on dose rate.
So you had to factor that in to understand when this would be activated.
And also, the actinium, potentially because of its higher LET
and the higher RBE effect,
did activate a greater magnitude of type one interferon
response. That particular story, I think, is
very interesting and much more complicated than this initial study let on.
And one of our current graduate students, Yuxuan Wang, is in the audience here and
has a poster at this meeting, and she has some very interesting
data about comparisons of alpha and beta from both
a dosimetry and immune activation standpoint.
So give her a visit.
Interestingly, when we combined and compared
alpha emitting actinium versus beta emitting Y90 or lutetium
in different tumor models, we got different results.
In an immunogenic model, MC38, that responds well
already to immune checkpoint inhibition,
the beta emitters were most effective in combination.
In a poorly immunogenic model that did not respond, had de novo
resistance to
checkpoint inhibition, the alpha emitter was most effective.
When we functionally looked at the effects of these on T cell
recognition and response to tumor cells, we could take T cells from
these mice and co-culture them with tumor cells.
The Y90 promoted a functional activation of T cells.
When they saw the tumor cells that they had been
treated against, they promoted a
gamma
interferon production, robustly consistent with tumor
recognition and a functional activation.
In contrast, when we did deep sequencing and single-cell
sequencing of
the T cells and CD45 positive immune cells from tumor,
and we looked at the
TCR sequences that were shared amongst expanded effectors and
effector memory cells, so evidence of
immune activation that occurred in these mice against their
cancer and that were generating effective memory response.
Only the actinium in combination with checkpoint blockade
increased the number of clones identified,
consistent with an effect on priming.
And so this data is consistent with the possibility that the alpha
emitter
led to an immune priming event with a greater T cell
diversification of the T cells recognizing tumor neoantigens,
whereas the other beta emitters simply expanded and
activated pre-existing immune recognition of tumor.
That story, I think, has very interesting potential for how we might
select patients.
That would suggest, for example, that an alpha emitter would be more effective in
combination with immune checkpoint blockade if treating those who had never
responded, whereas a beta might be only effective in those patients who
once responded and developed acquired as opposed to de novo resistance.
But that story also, I think, is more complicated than that
picture would lead one to believe.
It's very interesting, I'm glad we published it.
But in additional data, we
see different effects of radiation dose heterogeneity that
may be involved in that, and which may not so specifically
relate to the isotope and the emission profile,
but rather the microdosimetry that we're achieving with these
emitters, and the fact that actinium or very short-range
alpha emitters are going to create a very heterogeneous distribution of radiation
because of their short range.
So another graduate student in the lab, Maya Takashima, has been
investigating dose heterogeneity of radiopharmaceuticals and the
effect of that heterogeneity on immune response.
This built from work that we had published previously that was led by Justin
Jagodinski, who is a talented MD-PhD student, who did studies
looking at brachytherapy and external beam, where we came
across an interesting immunologic effect of dose heterogeneity,
which was that a distribution of radiation that had high,
moderate, and low doses in one tumor was most effective
in promoting antitumor immunity compared to any single
homogeneous dose. So building from that, Maya generated a
model here. Now this is a model, and it's not using FAP as it
normally would be, but we exogenously expressed FAP on the tumor cells.
So independent of the previous questions that we had, this is simply a model.
This is not about the agent itself.
But it gave us a tool to create tumors that
either uniformly express the target of the radiopharmaceutical
or that were mixed of positive and negative cells so that we could control the
heterogeneity. And you can see that here, these are IQID images where
a homogeneous tumor-- There's always some degree of heterogeneity because we're
delivering this through blood, and blood is not evenly distributed.
But
if the tumor is heterogeneous in its uptake, that heterogeneity is
even further amplified, as we see here with a mixed positive and
negative FAP expression tumor. And when we do dosimetry on
these and microdosimetry, we can generate dose volume histograms, and you
can see the effects where in a mixed model, you preserve more
of the tumor that does not get even a low
doseBut at the same time, when you're giving the same mean
dose, you get a higher hotspot as well.
So you elongate this dose volume histogram in a mixed
model. And when you do that, as I mentioned at the intro,
many of the mechanisms of how radiation affects immune response are
dose responsive. And so if you spread out the range of dose, you
can potentially activate more mechanisms in one tumor,
achieving regions that activate low dose and regions that activate high
dose. So comparing different mean tumor doses, it
took a high mean tumor dose with a homogeneous model to activate
MHC upregulation. It took a moderate dose to
activate type one interferon response, and a low mean tumor dose to optimally
activate some of our ICAM or other endothelial adhesion receptor
upregulation. But in the heterogeneous model, we could see activation
of all of those pathways in one tumor because of the heterogeneity.
When we give a heterogeneous dose of radiation,
somewhat contrary to what I would have expected, we initially were planning to only
do this study in combination with checkpoint blockade.
But what we observed, even with monotherapy, was that a heterogeneous
distribution that had colder cold spots and hotter hot spots gave a
better response here, and also achieved improved
overall survival.
And if you depleted CD8 T cells, you eliminated that effect.
So this, I think, poses a very interesting question, which is,
there is likely a degree to which the response to radiation alone is mediated
by immunity. It's also mediated through direct damage
on tumor cells from the radiation.
And in different models or different patients, different tumor types,
the impact of radiation damage and the impact of immune killing may vary.
And in some cases, where a tumor is particularly responsive to immune
response, it may be better, even in monotherapy settings, to
take into consideration this immunoradiobiology.
Because it doesn't make sense dosimetrically or from a radiation biology
standpoint
to say that you would get a better response when you spare more region of the
tumor in cold zones, unless you
implicate an immune response. But that could be
behind some of the findings that were alluded to earlier and that have been found
in many large studies with Plovecto and potentially
the
neuroendocrine tumor data, where mean tumor responses are not predictive of
response, whereas sometimes maximum SUV
is.
Mechanistically, this immune-based response to heterogeneity,
we believe, is at least in part due to
that dendritic cells, which are responsible for antigen
cross-presentation, are functionally preserved in cold dose
regions, and they can take advantage of the high dose regions to
uptake antigen and to be activated to then migrate to tumor-draining
lymph nodes. And so when we look in the homogeneous versus
heterogeneous models and take out tumor-draining lymph nodes after
treatment, we see more
dendritic cells arriving at that tumor-draining lymph node following heterogeneous
radiation compared to homogeneous radiation.
And then subsequent to that, about five days
later, when we look in those... Sorry,
at the same time, those homogeneous models have a
detrimental effect on very radiation-sensitive T cells, and so you get
more depletion in the tumor because you don't preserve cold spots.
And then, as I started to say, subsequent to that, by about day 12, because those
dendritic cells went to the tumor-draining lymph node, in the heterogeneous
model, you're seeing increased levels of T
cells arriving back, and it also has a striking effect on
the Treg to CD8 favorable
distribution of effector to suppressor T cell distribution there.
And in this setting,
we also, when we look at TCR sequencing, see evidence
of immune priming, where we see clonal
diversification. And so it could be that the
result we saw with actinium was because it was in part preserving
cold dose regions in those tumor models.
It could be because alphas do different things.
I think both of those are true, and this is why we're still doing
research.
What it means translationally is very interesting
and yet complicated. I believe that when we think about these
combinations, there won't be one dose that I can tell you, two
gray mean tumor or five. It's going to be specific to the agent you
give, to the isotope you give. But what we
believe is that the optimal dosimetry for combination of
any radiopharmaceutical with an immune checkpoint inhibitor will be a
dose that, number one, does not induce lymphopenia.
So staying below a systemic toxicity level that wipes out your T
cells. That will be counterproductive.
Number two, gives the maximum dose that you can to the tumor
microenvironment while still preserving about 20% of the tumor getting
below two gray.
That is consistent with this data, despite what we originally thought was
very heterogeneous data, which is that different models had a
best dose, different
isotopes with the same model had a different optimal dose.
But each of these data, which seemingly are
in disagreement when it looks at what dose is best, do agree when
you look at the microdosimetry and the distribution and the preservation of cold
dose regions.
So in conclusion, when we think about the opportunity to combine
radiopharmaceuticals with immunotherapy, I think there's enormous opportunity.
It's a complex story that will benefit from further investigation
preclinically and in carefully designed early phase clinical studies.
The opportunity extends not only to immune checkpoint inhibitors.
I think there's a lot of biology here that is created that creates new
targets for immunotherapies. And there's also the opportunity
where priming is not possibleTo combine with synthetic
adaptive immunity or CAR T cells, and this is an area
where we may not necessarily need to prioritize
priming, but where you could prioritize propagation of existing
immune response. And Kwabe Sogy, Amanda Shea, who just
defended her PhD last week
successfully,
have led investigations in our group looking at these types of combinations,
showing very strong
synergistic responses with very low doses of radiopharmaceuticals and
CAR T cells in solid tumors.
So with that, I'll close, and happy to take any questions.
Hi, Zach. Thanks for a really nice
presentation. I think combinations with RLTs is probably where things are heading
next. However, one of the key questions that we
continue to ponder on is, as you combine these expensive therapies,
RLTs plus CAR Ts, RLTs plus IOs, how do you
expect the payers to respond in the current
climate?
Well, hopefully, we will be achieving curative endpoints, and the costs will be
justified, and hopefully, you all will continue to innovate and create
competition that drives costs down.
But,
I think if the clinical data bears it out and
shows that the response is there, and we're achieving improved overall
survival or curative endpoints, then
it'll be worthwhile.
Yeah.
Hi, Dr. Morris. Really interesting talk.
It helps us to see that heterogeneity may be a feature, not a bug,
which is what we've always kind of heard.
But a question about preclinical advancement, right?
There are
a lot of cases where we may have tumor types for which we don't have models
like B16, right? Where we don't have syngeneic, and we can't look at the immune
impacts. How do we progress the field in those cases?
Yeah. I think,
likely,
the difference between a mouse melanoma and a human melanoma
is as great or more than the difference between a
mouse melanoma and a mouse head and neck cancer.
So personally, I don't feel it's that critical that
we say, "If we're going to translate something in head and neck cancer, we got to
show it in a syngeneic mouse head and neck cancer model." I think we can
study the principles that we're talking about here, and then I think we need
to design and get to phase one studies
quicker and invest in the
science that's
coming from the biopsies and blood in those.
And we could test these types of things in phase one studies, and
that can be a much more translatable scientific
endeavor than any of the mouse studies.
I think the mouse studies are critical because we have to have a starting point to
guide. But that will take
an investment in, whether it's from grants or companies, in
that correlative science and the time to dive into that before
jumping to phase two without the input of all the data
that's going to come out of those correlates.
Thank you.
Dr. Morris, congratulations on the beautiful work.
Actually, I have a question. Could you comment on the
effect of different
radio drugs on the innate immunity, such
as tumor-associated macrophages, myeloid
immune-suppressive cells?
Yeah. It's a great question.
We have looked to some extent at that, and as have
others, but not as exhaustively or not in as much
depth. In general, I would say following
radiopharmaceuticals, radioisotopes, and other radiation, you
see increased infiltration by
myeloid cells, M1, M2 macrophages.
Initially, that might be
more of the M1 type polarization. I know those are not perfect
dichotomies, of course. But over time, progression
over weeks or months towards more of a suppressive myeloid environment.
MDSCs also come in following this.
Those degrees to which that happens may vary by different tumor
types.
Those are both examples, I think, of potentials for additional
combination, where some of what we achieve with
radiopharmaceuticals may be suppressed by
the resultant immune-suppressive responses, the fibrotic
responses, and those may contribute to either a detriment in response
or maybe late toxicity to fibrosis in the context of external beam
and create new druggable targets for combination.
Thank you.
Yep.
Hi, Zach. Great talk as always.
Thanks.
What are your thoughts on the dose rate and some of the
shorter-lived versus longer-lived isotopes that we
use in these settings? Thinking astatine or lead, obviously.
Yep.
Even maybe a shorter-lived beta, like copper-67 or something like that.
Do you think
the residual radioactivity is potentially an
issue for
immune cells that are-
Yeah. I think having sort of a faster off rate
is a potential advantage,
in that there's a time course to immune response.
And so if, for example, you're priming new response,
you don't want to be killing those T cells as they come
back. Typically takes about a week or two to prime and then
clonally expand T cells fromA
vaccine or other. So you've got a window of time there
where in the tumor microenvironment, if you're still giving
radiation, you're not probably depleting some of the T cells that are
being clonally expanded in your tumor-draining lymph node, and then they're going
to come back. But if you're still giving radiation after that,
then you probably are battling against yourself.
You've created and clonally expanded T cells, and then you're killing them as they
arrive. So, I think that's an important
consideration.
You've got two online questions in. Yeah.
Thank you very much for the very interesting talk.
I'm quite curious to hear your opinion on
what is the best dosing interval or the schedule between
radiation or any other combination partners and immunotherapy in
order to really have the best response, because I'm still
puzzled for this point, and I'm quite curious to hear your opinion.
Yeah. It's a great question. I don't have an absolute answer to that.
I'll say in published work, we showed that earlier introduction
of checkpoint blockade, even before the radiopharmaceutical, was more
effective. But I would caution that in mice, there's an
enormous time bias to these types of studies, and if you start any
therapy earlier in mice, because the tumors grow so quickly that you have a
time bias that you're treating smaller tumors with your second
therapy, basically. And so I don't think that that's a question that we
can very readily address in preclinical studies
and either work with companion canines or Phase 1 is where I would do that.
There is data with combination with external beam radiation that
in
lung cancer, where
there seems to be a very important effect of the timing of radiation
relative to
immune checkpoint inhibitors, but even there, we don't have that fully worked out.
My suggestion would be maybe to take patients who are on the
immune checkpoint inhibitor, where you're not going to detract from their
response and maybe wait to see, because some of them will have a beautiful
response, and if we do anything, we could only harm them,
and let those patients declare themselves and then
introduce this therapy after initial imaging to patients who are
either showing de novo resistance or
developing acquired resistance.
Just a short follow-up question on this.
Because I also heard before that maybe immunotherapy is quite
effective in minimal residual diseases, so radiation or
chemotherapy would be a tool to really debulk the
tumors to give the chance to immunotherapy.
So what do you also think on this?
Yeah, absolutely. I think these are going to be integrated in different
contexts, and so if we're talking about adding
immunotherapy to radiopharmaceutical, then absolutely, it'll likely be done
afterwards, and you'll have debulked, and that way you can take advantage.
If we're adding radiopharmaceuticals to checkpoint inhibition, which
proportionally is more likely just given indications right now, that's what I was
talking about.
Okay.
I think we have to close this out. I'm sorry to the online chat.
We didn't quite have enough time.
Happy to take questions up here if anybody didn't get a chance.
Yeah.
Great. Thank you.